he's from seattle university the
baseball factory
yeah had tommy john in college
baseball america into this year had him
as their number two prospect
so kind of
learning on the on the fly here at the
big league level i mentioned the home
runs have been an issue for him he's
allowed 10
in 27 innings of work
that's 3.33 home runs per nine innings
catcher
wilson contreras leads off payoff to
contreras and he got him looking
contreras thought he had drawn a walk
good call from the home plate umpire
john tom payne one up and one down 96 on
the fastball just love it boy that high
release from him brian's playing center
field for the cubs tonight
bryant leads the majors and extra base
hits and doubles off to a really good
start here's the o2
swung out and miss
back to back punch outs for tarik skubal
and that one was really quick just three
pitches to dust bryant that's what the
tigers want to see go right after him
this is a very good breakable look at
the depth in this
that had some bite
down and in how about rizzo he's on top
of the plate boy is he
swinging a pop-up
playable by home plate rogers tosses the
mask away makes the catch on the dirt
track to the left of the old english d
rizzo pops out and a terrific one two
three for terek skubal jake arietta on
the mound for the cubs three and three
on the year
you see the numbers right there um
got sheldon's last start fastball was
only 89 miles an hour that's the lowest
of his career curveball can be nasty
head out towards center field there's
chris bryant
that's the candelario lifted to left
field shallow and playable for peterson
the left-handed left fielder will snatch
that one and that's out number two
no score we're in the first inning there
has not been a base runner yet the
payoff from jake arrieta
cabrera hits a high pop fly
it's playable in foul territory for
anthony rizzo there's a lot of room and
foul ground here also
rizzo makes the catch
tigers go one two three we go to inning
number two cubs nothing detroit nothing
the 1-0
is laced into right field and that's a
base hit
so bodhi got a fastball and took it the
other way
and with one out of man aboard
as david reaches on the single to bring
up jack peterson 0-2
hit hard base hit left field
jack peterson staying hot against the
lefty in fact now five for his last six
against left-handers trying to keep
things simple try to hit a line drive
over the shortstop's head go ally to ali
when you're in your thought process cubs
trying to take the early lead something
you always want to do one two
in the air that's out towards right
center field jones gliding back makes
the catch tagging from second is bodhi
and they'll be at the corners with two
outs matt duffy
put a pretty good charge into that one
here's a swing and a bouncer toward the
middle glove by the shortstop goodrum
goes to second there's the force that's
the inning the cubs get a couple of
singles but they walk away empty-handed
now chris bryant this is the bat to
watch in this lineup now the 1-1 from
scuba to bryant
chris will drive one in the air right
field deep pretty well hit back goes
missouri it's got a chance gone
chris bryant with his 10th homer of the
year
in his major league leading 24th extra
base hit the cubs jump out it is two
nothing kb goes apple great swing stays
down above the ball with the swing
drives right down through it it's in
about the second row of seats to
straight right field excellent swing by
kb and the cubs take the lead and the
batter will be miguel cabrera cabrera
popped out foul his first time here
comes the one two
ground ball to short could be too biased
to horner one over to rizzo double play
six four three it ends the inning the
tigers do not score four shutout innings
for arietta so runners at the corners
now with just one away in the top half
of the fifth inning scooble delivers
this is hit in the air to deep right
field it is off the wall in the corner
fairball hayward scores bryant races to
third he'll stop there and rizzo pulls
into second base with a stand-up double
an rbi for anthony and the cubs lead
three to nothing over the tigers here in
the fifth boy great swing by anthony he
stays on top of this ball it's a pitch
inside and just drops the head of the
bat on it and hits a line drive bullet
still only one out and now the cubs have
two men in scoring position infield in
the pitch
broken back pop up short center field
coming in jones converging the left
fielder it drops in
brian scores cubs increased the lead
four to nothing over the tigers here in
the fifth inning and rizzo had to stay
at second base it was a blue pop-up to
short left center field there was a
triumvirate converging jones from center
grossmann from left two down nobody on
jake rogers the batter three two to
rogers turns on one
left field
gone
jake rogers with his first home run of
the year
4-1 cubs he hung it
inside corner 88 mile an hour
see if that leads to something for the
tigers energizes that dugout
grossman turns on one deep to right
field back-to-back homers for the tigers
a one-hopper off the seats to the brick
wall and right center absolute no doubt
or the tigers go back-to-back
and then cut this lead to four to two
how about that another hanger and let me
tell you a bob buggy whip baby
the one out of matt duffy up the middle
on the backhand harold castro gets one
and two what a play by harold castro wow
you would have thought no chance could
you get that on your own but he did
harold castro ended up on the left field
side of second when he fielded it
good strong throw bring kim ralan to
close it out
that microscopic era of 0.64
a bunch of strikeouts
14 innings of work
swing and a miss and he's gone camera
coming back to the
swing
plate
a miss struck him out
and kimbrell's got the first two here in
the ninth jammer candelario the batter
struck him out he strikes out the side
ball game cubs win kimbrell in the cubs
bullpen tremendous in the final 4-2